okay let's see how this
goes
okay
yep there we go
so I don't know how this is gonna go
starting off with a new channel new
streaming Channel
I don't know exactly how many people are
gonna be watching us
live but
I wanted to
stream here as I get going with this
stream and then it just matters that
it's up it's uploaded somewhere so I
don't know how many people are going to
be here live and that's okay we don't
have that many people because
it's really that streaming it's really
I'm just like live streaming the process
of streaming the process
of recording the video for it so it's
like
I'll probably edit this later and then
re-upload it
but yeah streaming streaming
nice nice nice
feels good to settle into a new channel
I feel like um
this live stream is going to be a lot
more intimate
AKA says I couldn't find episodes five
through ten with Subs I didn't want to
join the channel they were on
yeah I'm not sure I just watched it on
um on tencent on the on the tencent
YouTube channel
so yeah
someone says I want my roommate to see
this but he hasn't read them yet he's
only watching so far interesting
interesting yeah so we're going to talk
about um episodes five through ten or
really just talk about like the show in
general and like where it's gone since
the first
few episodes because I feel like now
it's we've gotten into some different
territorial with some things in the show
so we'll get to that
um and yeah
I'll be right back
and now I am back so we will get to the
review
and just a little bit
so um
yeah so keep in mind spoilers for the
show
I'm still enjoying this show a lot I
think that
there are some things though that I feel
like are a little bit like
so the main thing is okay I think that
30 episodes might be a little bit too
much I was very excited
about having 30 episodes at first but as
I'm seeing like the show continue to go
on and the pacing of the show
I feel like this might have been better
with 24 episodes because now what I'm
seeing like past episode four is uh a
lot of
added characters a lot of um extending
of characters that already exist like
Dasha extended roll
um we've got an extended role of like
zubing Bing very extended role she did
basically nothing in in the book
um and we also got like invented
characters like musing totally new I'm
just riding around on the scooter I have
no idea what's up with that character I
found like a lot of that stuff to be
like rather like
I don't like not not very interesting
compared to what happens in the book and
I think this is because we're giving
like a lot of the minor characters
um I guess I guess it probably has
something to do with actors I'm not sure
how the contracts work
but I feel like it probably has
something to do with the actors actors
having contracts that like they have to
be in multiple episodes
um and they do that in American
television shows when it comes to
adaptations too like once you hire an
actor they have to be in a certain
amount of episodes you have to keep
using them but um here a lot of that
feels like it just feels like it really
gives me a big filler vibe
and I don't like enjoy watching some of
that stuff as much as the stuff that's
like directly taken from the book and
also um
a lot of things are out of order from
the book as far as I can tell I know
that this is the Chinese adaptation of
the book
I know that there is the Chinese
adaptation so I feel like maybe this
show is based more off of the Chinese
version of the book because I hear
certain things take place in different
orders and it remains to be seen if like
everything is going to be included but
we'll see we'll see we'll see
I did say in my last video that um
certain things with yeah wenji might
have been censored in the Chinese
version of the book but apparently
that's not true apparently like the
stuff with the um
uh the cultural revolution happens later
in the book uh versus the show
um we did get that to that in episode 10
just a little bit but one thing I
noticed is that
what they're showing in episode 10 with
yawinji is actually like the second
chapter
of the red Coast thing in the book it's
the second time you see her young like
the first time you see her is in a
different circumstance and I'm very
interested if they're going to show that
first time that we encountered Yahweh G
and the show
but
we'll see if they do that
um
so yeah uh what else what else
um so yeah I think because it's 30
episodes because it's so extended
um
I think that's the reason there's so
much reiterating and there's so many
like that that's the reason there's so
much redundancy that I see happening and
so many like dragging episodes because
um they'll spend a lot of time just kind
of
recapping things that we already know
about that we've like
and they're saying it over and over
again yangdong committed suicide because
of this and I'm like you're just like
discussing stuff that we already know
and it really makes it drag for me I
don't know if they're reiterating it
just because like
they don't think people are going to
understand it
I don't know that's a little for me
weird
um death note says I like the changes I
don't know I mean I can't find any
change I don't
I don't like any other changes I have to
say I mean the changes don't make the
story better it's not that I'm like
actively disliking everything that's
changed but I don't think all the
changes make the story better like for
instance there's a lot more Dasha Dasha
enters the game with him in the show
version
and he does doesn't do anything he's
just there I mean the scene isn't really
different it's just Dasha is there and
then there's the weird part of the show
where like inside of the game Wang runs
to rescue rescue Basha
and I'm like why are you trying to
rescue him you're in a you're in a game
you're playing a game like to me that
was just like weird it's like you're
just inserting Dasha into the scene for
whatever reason and I feel like that
and uh his assistants living are
just kind of inserted into a lot of
scenes where it's just like can we just
move on to the actual interesting parts
of the story like I felt like it took
way too long to get to the yawinji
flashback like episode 10 I feel like
should have maybe been around episode
seven or six honestly I feel like we
could have cut a lot of stuff and got to
episode 10 a lot faster
I thought the game sequences were
actually pretty interesting because
that's such an interesting and like
weird trippy part of the book where
you're just trying to understand what's
going on so I think the game parts are
pretty cool
uh has a lot of Mystery
but yeah I'm not sure about just like
some of the character extensions that's
a little weird for me
um
and so I wanted to say that I did like
watch a couple just watch a little bit
of some
Chinese dramas just to get like a sense
of what it's like
um
what what Chinese shows are like and I
definitely feel like the three writer
problem show has a little bit of that
Chinese drama feel where like certain
things are just like a little bit
melodramatic
um certain things are just like a little
bit like tonally like weird sometimes
it's like a little goofy sometimes
and I definitely think that is a little
bit strange to me as an American
American seeing like it's like very
serious and then they'll cut to
something that's kind of like a little
bit Goofy and weird and I'm just like Ah
that's a little weird
um
so that was a little bit like uh
something that threw me off I definitely
think that the Netflix version will be a
lot more
dreary compared to uh the show a lot
more just like dark consistently dark
because I feel like the tone of this
show like changes a little bit
for sure someone
um a logos says has anybody noticed how
good the outro song is like when you
really read the lyrics that's
it's a pretty good song I I it's weird
because I can tell like a lot of the
songs that they're using they seem like
original songs
um but some of them have the lyrics
translated to English
and they're being sung in English and
it's a little bit weird because it's
like it doesn't rhyme and um they're not
really grammatically correct it's like
I've seen the future your people won't
believe and it's like okay
it's a little weird I kind of wish just
just sing it in in Mandarin Chinese you
know probably better
but yeah
uh most of the music is pretty good
though pretty dark pitch bendy type
sounds
yeah but like I said
um okay so far so far um I think that uh
yeah
someone says both tracks intro and out
tracks stay in my mind I quite like them
they're pretty catchy
I wasn't gonna say okay so yeah I think
my highlights of the show so far
um as far as episode five through ten
are the game scene I really enjoy the
whole sequence of the game
um I'm seeing the dehydration I thought
was really cool
um
because I always wondered like reading
the book you only have your own
imagination to try and like make this
landscape come to life so it's cool to
finally have a visualization of what it
potentially was like
um so that's very very interesting to
see the pyramids and the pendulums
um in the dehydration process but like
like I said I can't only imagine what
it's like for people that have not read
the book to watch this show I feel like
this is not
this is not a show that's for people
that haven't read the book because how
are you going to catch up with it and
there's a lot of things that are weirdly
weirdly different and someone just
mentioned wool Buck Dasha strapping the
bomb to his chest that isn't in the book
that is not in the book at all I don't
know what that scene
was supposed to mean
or I don't know if Wang was supposed to
find that endearing to me that was a
very weird thing and to me like the
weirdest things in the show are not in
the book at all
um there was a very weird sequence
in the show where Wang is in his
daughter's classroom and all the kids
just
clap
for like five minutes straight at his
speech and these are like little kids
like elementary school children and I
remember just watching it like what
I have no idea what that was supposed to
be about that was super strange and not
in the book so a lot of the little weird
things that I'm just like I don't know
if that should be there it's pretty much
all coming from like
just additional things that have been
added not sure what's up with that I'm
not sure if like
I don't know I haven't watched enough
Chinese shows to like have a basis of
comparison I haven't watched enough
enough Chinese adaptations of Science
Fiction things have a basis of
comparison and know if like other things
like do
similar types of you know little things
that don't match tonally with what I'm
used to you know what I mean
it just seemed like super out of place
someone says the game looks pretty much
like what I imagined yeah it is it is
cool seeing it visualized for sure
and it does look pretty much like what I
imagined
um they definitely kind of captured the
dreamlike state of it I think
where it's like ah this is really like
weird and uh I don't know it was very
cool
but then again for me again it was kind
of kind of weirded out by the fact that
Dash Dasha is there for no reason and
it's just very very strange to me
in general I enjoy watching I have
enjoyed watching the show so far we've
been watching it every night I think
they skipped one night I think they
skipped Saturday but I've been enjoying
the show I've been enjoying the show in
general for sure it's a nice treat
um except I mean there was at least one
episode where I felt like kind of
dragged a little bit too much it might
have been
episode six maybe or maybe it was like
episode nine this has been a couple
episodes where I felt like almost could
have been cut
down either a lot or like cut entirely
because they just really dragged and it
was like kind of just reiterating a lot
of stuff like I said
but yeah
um so far we've been really building
um
the mystery and the tension surrounding
the frontiers of Science and
ETO you got Dasha and you got zubing
being trying to figure out what's going
on I'm not really sure what the role of
the reporter character that wasn't in
the book musing is was trying to figure
out what's going on with the frontiers
of Science and what I'm not really sure
what her role is going to be ultimately
um
I don't know if it's coming from the
fact that I already know what's going on
or if it's just like or if it really is
just super Meandering but I feel like I
already know what the deal is so it's
like seeing them meander about it
especially with all the additional like
screen time giving to minor characters
just to me is it's definitely the least
interesting parts of the show I feel
like there's some really rough stuff and
I feel like just now in episode 10 are
we getting to like the stuff that's the
most interesting about the book right so
if you haven't watched the show yet if
you can just get to episode 10 I think
the um the
the game episodes are good but if you
can just get to episode 10 I feel like
that's when it really picks up I haven't
seen episode 11 yet it's not out until
tomorrow but I feel like episode 10 is
really where um
the game kind of picks up will the where
the show kind of picks up because I
enjoy seeing
the yeah wenji flashback and that could
just be me subconsciously to knowing
where that All Leads
so maybe that's why I like
um that part better that's that um
episode better than what I've seen so
far with episodes five through nine
but it remains to be seen
um so far I think even with the added
content the show is pretty close to the
book it's relatively close to the book
um like I said apparently according to
um some of my Chinese followers it's
more similar to the Chinese version of
the book than it is the American version
of the book which makes sense because
the American version of the book is the
adaptation it's translated
um so it makes sense that some things
are
mixed around but um so far with the show
I don't think that really much of
anything is being left out some things
are being augmented lots of things are
being added I don't think anything is
being left out for instance on things
that are being added I think the show is
really taking its time to show you how
the frontiers of science works with ETO
to take down scientists that are doing
important work or a work that's going to
lead to the development of something
important I feel like uh the show is
showing you that more so than the book
is and I think that's just so that
people will understand that when we get
to the bigger reveals later on so I
think people it's so that people
understand
what exactly the function of ETO is and
how exactly they are involved with the
scientist suicides because I don't think
that it's just like oh they tell them
that they're turkey scientists and that
makes them insane it's like how we're
seeing with Wang
um where they're doing things to like
affect them physically you know they're
projecting lights onto their eyes and we
also see that with another character
who's having the lights projected upon
his eyes and he almost dies because can
you imagine if you're seeing something
in your field of vision and it doesn't
make any sense that everyone's telling
you that it's not there
that might drive you insane at some
point you might just want it to stop
what I think is very interesting about
Wayne Wang as a character too is that
he's kind of just dealing with it you
know what I mean Wang is just kind of um
he's kind of like just green and bearing
it he's like okay I'm not stopping my
research I'll deal with the numbers on
my face and I think that's admirable of
weighing I guess
uh
let's see let's see okay there was also
um a weird dance sequence with Dasha in
one of the episodes that I'm just like
why is I think that wasn't might have
been
near the scene or the same scene where
he has the bomb
on his chest which wasn't in the book
and then there's a weird dance sequence
that wasn't the book I don't know what
that was about but cool I'm just trying
to think from memory
um
all the things about the show that I
liked and the things that I thought were
weird I said in the first review that um
the show was good but it definitely
takes some use to getting to some of the
things that are different about it
um versus American shows like when it
comes to American TV shows and American
Productions we're used to ver we're used
to a certain type of thing and this is
definitely different
um sometimes it's weirdly slow and
sometimes it's weirdly she's like silly
you know
um so
it's definitely an adjustment
to get used to watching this you know
and I don't think that this is a show
for everybody I don't think this is
really a show for the average American I
think the average American would
definitely get pretty bored and
frustrated with this show pretty quickly
um because of just how like
gradual it all is and how like every
episode isn't really like a big moment
it's kind of like just all kind of
continual and there's a lot like like I
said a lot of reiteration with not that
much payoff every episode so I think a
lot of people might just get frustrated
bored and tired and I think a lot of
people are gonna turn I think a lot of
people a lot of Americans would probably
not watch past the first three episodes
of this show
foreign
someone says that dance is kind of a
meme in China that's insane
yeah a dance is kind of a mean and meme
in China interesting I didn't know that
someone says episode 11 is out right now
excellent oh yeah you're right because I
did episode 10 yesterday so we're gonna
watch episode 11 tonight and then we'll
come back here like
next week later this week one of these
days and stream episode stream about
episode 11 through however many I
watched up until that point
ah
someone says uh Romina Jones says I'm
preferring this to American style shows
American shows move too quick here we
sink into a scene and the atmosphere
builds up
um it's definitely an adjustment to get
used to
um and I I don't mind watching something
that's more slow a little bit more
cerebral more like just like a lot
characters talking I don't mind watching
that but I do think that
the average American is not going to get
into this show and like it very much I
will say
um unless you're really into the free
body problem like I am so you know what
I mean
yeah but the show's also not made for
Americans it's made for a Chinese
audience like we're getting an American
version of this
I tried to get my roommates to sit down
and watch an episode where they got
bored after an episode and a half
yeah I totally believe it because it's a
I totally believe it
let me close out the window
neighbors dogs are barking
pay no attention to the fact that I'm
wearing it
Alex so loud
okay
I was gonna say pay no attention to the
fact that I'm wearing sweatpants with a
Blazer but I don't even think you can
see that so
anyway
Quinn do you think the Netflix series
will have some chance to be good as this
one I think the Netflix series is gonna
have to be very different
I don't know how many episodes they're
gonna get
um
it could potentially be good
but it's going to be really different
you know what I mean things are going to
have to be changed and um adapted more
heavily I think than in this one
um just to make things move a little bit
better for like a 10 episode format
unless they give book one more than 10
episodes which I really can't
I really can't see them giving book one
more than 10 episodes for Netflix
because I feel like like I said when it
comes to an American audience getting
people to stay
um and continue to watch something you
need every episode to be like
like a whole like moment you need you
need every episode to be a moment and
you need to end the series on a big bang
and so I think the ending of the
three-body problem where we have this
big reveal as to what's really going on
I think if we don't get that in season
one of the American show there's almost
no chance that that show will get
another season I feel like Americans
like at this point are not okay with
like watching 10 episodes or something
and then not having like the big moment
where they know what's going on and they
like we need the moment to get them
excited excited for the next season
because I don't think if you end it
halfway through book one that Americans
are going to be excited for the next
half of it in my opinion
foreign
says I love your work man can you please
do a review of all tomorrows I think it
had some Cosmic horror elements I've
heard of altamaros I'm pretty sure alt
shift X has a big video on all tomorrows
um I have not read any of that um people
have recommended it to me but uh I just
haven't yet so
maybe if I read and I get into it and
that might be something that we'll do
all right so
I don't know if you guys have noticed I
don't know what link you guys I don't
know how people watching this got to
this stream I posted this link in
several different places but this is my
new streaming Channel I'm gonna be
streaming on this channel
um
pretty much from now on we'll we won't
be screaming on Quinn's ideas very much
just this channel
um
and the reason I'm doing this is just
because I want to stream about more
different types of things and stream
more often and it's just I think better
to have the streams on a different
channel so um I didn't know how many
people were going to be watching this
stream how many people were going to
show up to this because it's a new
channel but we've got some people here
and just make sure you hit the like
button because that also helps always on
any channel and yeah yeah yeah
so I also put up a little poll here that
you guys can vote on do you like the
show yes no it's okay I haven't seen it
looks like 70 people saying yeah
78 of people said yeah
so awesome
that is really awesome did you read
children of memory I don't think
children of memory is out
here yet is it it might be but I don't
think it is so I have not read children
of memory and that is the third book in
Adrian Tchaikovsky's awesome science
fiction series now that starts with
Children Of Time children of Ruin and
children of memory
but yeah
someone says it is so children of memory
is out interesting so yeah
um
someone says the cinematography is a
little odd at times I have to say yeah
but I kind of
I kind of give them a break for you know
this kind of TV show that's 30 episodes
I don't know how true this is but I
heard that like perhaps
this is a rumor that one episode of the
Netflix version
is the same cost to make as like 20
episodes of this show just one episode
of the Netflix version is like 20
episodes of this one so
yeah
um so I give them a little bit I'll give
them a little bit of break on some
cinematography sometimes because they
have so much to do you know they've got
so much to get done with this
someone says I've never read the book I
only have your videos as a reference but
I love this show that's awesome
typically what's curious about my videos
is that I never really talk about I
don't talk about the first book on my
videos as much usually in my videos I'm
talking about what's what's happening in
death death's end and um the Dark Forest
because I feel like those are the two
books where things are really really get
interesting this first book is just the
introduction
um the first book is just the
introduction so yeah
and I feel like this show um
this I feel like people watching the
show now even if you've seen all 10
episodes and you haven't read the books
you don't really know where this is
going at all like I feel like this show
so far is surrounding ETO you don't
really I actually um you did have Dasha
say wonder if Sean Sean yifan was an
alien that was interesting that was
interesting that's not I don't think I
don't think that's in the book I don't
think he says that but in the show it's
like oh is she an alien and they do keep
mentioning the farmer so they're kind of
implying that alien things are happening
but generally the show seems to be
really focusing on like I said earlier
um what's the deal with ETO what's to
deal with the scientist suicides and
what's to deal with this like weird game
who made this game and what's going on
with physics
so it's it's not like what the point of
the series is ultimately it's like
really grounded at this point it's a
really really grounded on Earth at this
point and those of you that read the
books know that it really really takes
off and expands as it goes on
someone says it's impressive how well
acted and well written the show is each
episode doesn't usually have more than a
couple of different settings and a lot
of recurrent sets which I imagine helps
with the production costs that's
definitely true you'll be curious to see
what
the next season is going to be like you
know the Dark Forest book that'll be
really interesting to see
um because they definitely have to have
more CGI in the dark forest and more
like
weirder and interesting looking sets in
the dark Forest so if they do get to
that you'll be curious to see what it's
like and I do agree that the acting is
pretty consistent and solid there's a
little bit of woodiness from some of the
actors but I feel like the acting is
pretty consistent
um
yeah so definitely mad respect on the
acting for sure
someone says this may be an odd question
but what is your favorite genre of
literature
um
do you love to write also enjoying and
loving your new channel my dude
um
okay I'm just going to answer this in
two ways because I'm not sure which
exactly what you mean I do I my favorite
genre right now it switches all the time
I feel like um if you asked me like five
years ago I would have said fantasy but
right now it's definitely science
fiction I love reading science fiction
and as far as to write fantasy science
fiction I just the the feeling of uh
crafting my own world and making the own
my own rules to how that world works I
think is very compelling to me so yeah
so somewhat Philip Castello says I'm
going to watch the show once I start my
three body problem re-read I'm going to
read each part as the show covers it the
main actors are okay excellent excellent
I think that's a good idea uh James is
also reading the book right now as we're
watching the show and he's getting like
let out of that it's really great
because because he's reading it he
remember he can compare it actively to
what's happening in the show right now
so I'm like did this happen I don't
remember this he's like no that didn't
happen this happened that happened
differently but yeah I feel like the
changes like I said are are minimal it's
more like they're adding stuff than
removing stuff which I I prefer
attic stuff than removing stuff
have they announced that they're going
to do a dark Forest show says death
mullet they have not announced it but
it's really just my assumption
um the three buddy problem series is
very popular in China as far as I can
tell I went over on Billy Billy which is
basically like Chinese YouTube
and three buddy problem videos get
millions of views
over there so that's um
really interesting and also um I found
out the other day that actually a lot of
my videos have been uploaded to Billy
Billy and they've been uploaded for
years
um Hyperion videos Dune videos like
almost all of my three body problem
videos and they get mega mega views
um my live stream the last live stream I
did on the free body was uploaded
multiple times it's got like over 200
000 views like almost 300 000 views
between all the uploads and like the
version of it on YouTube has less than
50 000 views the one that I uploaded so
it's really insane to see that blow up
on like in another country
more so than I did here in the United
States it's really weird
okay let's see
if someone says hi Queen do you know
about the Billy Billy animated
adaptation of the second book The Dark
Forest it's critically panned in China
but has some interesting visuals I
actually avoided watching it because I
heard how bad it was from some of my
Chinese friends just saying don't bother
with it it's really terrible they kind
of just throw everything in the book out
so because of that um I kind of don't
really want to sit through it
um I'm sure there's some interesting
visuals but if it's really
that disrespectful to the source
material that I'm not really interested
you know because the Dark Forest is my
favorite book in the series
um
I feel like the Dark Forest is where the
series
really really takes off and gets really
really good this is like the height of I
feel like this is what science fiction
was made for the genre of Science
Fiction was created for books like this
and I'm just not okay with like sitting
through like a show that's like taking a
crap on it you know what I mean
I could totally watch uh the three body
problem because it's respectful to the
source material though it's like
different and I'm sure like the creators
are making changes I'm sure it's the
nest set and the necessity of it being
30 episodes right because you you have
to make changes to get it to fit in a
certain time frame so I get it but yeah
someone says luji is a Formula One
driver champion in the adaptation I'm
not sure what that means but okay
um
death mullet says that makes me really
curious what the Billy Billy show does
different maybe I'll take a peek at the
Billy Billy show and then the next time
we stream on this channel here by the
way if you're watching subscribe this is
the streaming Channel now
um
yeah um maybe I'll watch it and talk
about it maybe I'll watch a little bit
of it and talk about it because and
maybe I'll just end up cracking on it
so let's see um do you think some of the
scenes from The Dark fours can really be
done well on screens considering the
scope of some of the scenes and the
budget they are working with
um
I don't know I it depends on how much
money they have it depends on how much
money they have because in the dark
Forest
um we're we're seeing the future of
humanity and there's a lot of like outer
space stuff and and and and ship
spaceship stuff and cryo sleep and
there's a lot of time that passes by and
there's a lot more
variance in the scenes like the three
body problem takes place over the course
of a few months whereas the Dark Forest
takes place over the course of a
hundreds
well not yeah hundreds of years in the
dark Forest whereas a three writer
problem is months so it's it's a whole
different thing and
um
I will just have to see what they're
working with we'll just have to see what
they're working with
let's see my eye
I've been staring at a screen for way
too long my eyes
my eye gets super Twitchy sometimes when
I'm just like staring at the screen
um they didn't show yeah Wendy's
um how yeah when his dad really died
which is the Catalyst for the entire
plot yeah we got a tiny Glimpse at yet
wenji's dad laying in a bed but we have
not seen the death moment and I don't
know if that's gonna happen later I've
Been Told
by by people that have read the Chinese
adaptation that it does happen but later
in the book whereas like in the American
adaptation it's like the first chapter
so
it still remains to be seen whether
they're whether they're going to show
that and actually heard that I actually
heard from also a Chinese follower of
mine that um some people in China are a
little shocked that they even showed
what they showed in episode 10
so I don't know
um because of the political climate
apparently I don't know that much about
it because I'm don't really know that
much about Chinese history and Chinese
politics but
apparently that's kind of a touchy
subject over overseas
um someone says I can't be the only one
who is hypnotized by the light in the
background with all the moving lights
like that yeah all right that's a cool
light isn't it
um that's the same light that I use in a
bunch of my videos
yeah that's my dog ping she is really
lumped over
say hi
can you guys see
there she is
she's super lumped over
I don't know
why
she's so tired all the time she doesn't
do anything
doesn't do anything but lay on blankets
do anything to lay on blankets in a
plane
um
yeah
let's see
someone says how about the 4D stuff in
death's end
um yeah we've talked about that multiple
times on the channel it gets really
weird and trippy
um that's the part in the book once I
got to death's end
one thing that I was really surprised
about in Destin but the thing that I
loved reading is how it just
kept going right at some point you think
like how far are you gonna take this
shishin look like
how far are you going to keep taking
this story about Humanity because it's a
story about humans continuing to like
move forward and it's like this could go
on indefinitely and it really just like
keeps moving it keeps going for for
further and that's what I love about it
because it's a great piece of
speculative fiction and I think one p
one thing that people get hung up on
with this series for some reason
is that they'll be like oh well this
this is so scientifically improbable
this could never happen like this the
science is wrong in this and I'm just
like guys
Science Fiction it's science fiction we
got to emphasize the fiction part like
we don't watch Star Trek and then talk
about like how
I don't know the transporter could never
work or how the hollow deck can never
work it's about
the speculation of it it's about it's
the what if question that is the point
of science that's the fiction element we
take science and then we say well what
if it could be like this
what if it actually went down like this
and we could do this and we could make
this happen it's not about what's 100
scientifically accurate all the time I
think well some science books are like
that there's definitely some science
fiction books that are trying to be like
100 scientifically accurate with
what-ifs but that doesn't work all the
time sometimes that's just plain boring
sometimes we gotta have a little bit of
Make-Believe science fiction and I think
that's totally fine and I think that's
awesome and exciting you know it doesn't
have to be always 100 logical or 100
scientifically consistent
because lots of things that we love and
I feel honestly most of the science
fiction things that we love
it's most of it's impossible you know
most of it's impossible Like a Star Trek
could never happen not the way that it
happens in Star Trek
um and that's true for most science
fiction things so yeah
so
um Jing sung Yang says to film Dark
Forest would cost a lot of money if this
season does well there will be more
investors and you can expect the new
season will drag on even longer for more
ads it's been really curious seeing uh
all the Chinese ads
um I definitely prefer Chinese ads to
American ads I find American
advertisement to be just so
grading and annoying
um but Chinese ads are super quick they
show them and then they go and I much
prefer that to just like the drawn out
American ads that are just like trying
to manipulate you emotionally it's just
like can you stop can you just show me
the product and move on yeah so I much
prefer the Chinese ads
um
Jonah heck Mentor says episode 11 seems
to have lost the
um have lost 10 minutes somewhere
um it did feel like there was some
missing scene interesting okay I haven't
watched episode 11 yet but we'll see
we'll see
because it's it's definitely possible
that some things that were maybe even in
the original version of the show were
cut I don't know I don't know I don't
want to judge it before I see so House
of the Everlasting Shadow says Hey Quinn
I just wanted to say you're my favorite
YouTuber and I really appreciate what
you do thank you so much it's so nice so
nice also you know what's really nice
um I said that um I was looking at my
videos on Billy Billy I had no idea that
I had this whole other audience on Billy
Billy but the comments on Billy Billy
are so
sincere and nice and I think it's really
really great
um
I don't know that everyone's just so
friendly everyone's just like oh I I
love this content creator
um and I'm just like oh that's super
super nice
um and also I saw someone that said my
pronunciation was really good which is
so funny to me because like uh Americans
for some reason
always want to correct me on the Chinese
names
Americans or other you're saying it
wrong it's pronounced like this and you
better get these names right because
you're saying people's names wrong and
you're going to offend people and the
Chinese are just like we don't care
great pronunciation
because it's like they understand that I
don't speak Chinese so it's like I'm
gonna say a Chinese name with a Chinese
with an American accent so it's just
obviously right uh but to me that was a
really funny funny difference
oh and I think that I think that I think
it's hilarious really really hilarious
because I try to be as accurate as
possible with the names but you know no
none of it was going to be able to get
it if people say my name wrong all the
time you know my full name is Quinn
Darius right and that sounds pretty easy
to say quindarius right you have no idea
how many teachers College professors
random people in my life just for the
love of me can't pronounce it
any variation on it it's so weird super
weird so I never never I'm never like
hard on people when they can't get get a
name right because I'm not good with it
lots of people aren't it's fine it's
fine it's fine
um someone says chug says regarding the
accuracy of the adaptation how do you
feed how do you feel now versus how you
did the first four episodes okay I
definitely feel like my um opinion on it
has has shifted slightly I think I was
much more invested in the first four
episodes but as it has gone the dragging
bits of the show I feel like definitely
slow it down for me like um I feel like
it's definitely dragging on a little bit
longer and I did hear big rumor I don't
know if this is true I did hear that on
the original creators Wanted 24 episodes
or so
and that the network tencent or whatever
ordered 30 episodes so it seems that
perhaps additional
content had to be added that was more
filler
because of you know them needing six
more episodes and I think the original
cut the original script was probably a
lot more concise
oh everyone's saying episode 11 is slow
yeah so I'm feeling like the original
script was probably a lot more concise
which makes sense to me because I was
saying earlier that it just like if this
was like 20 episodes I feel like it
would be oh yeah this is a banger this
is a banger but because there's 30 it's
much much slower than I think should be
and it's almost like I wish I someone
could do a cut of this
that's more concise someone could do a
cut of it that's more concise
um because I feel like I feel a little
bit bad almost for the show creators
um if it's true that they had to add in
more episodes because it's like I know a
lot of people a lot of Americans have
stopped watching already and they'll
never watch anymore because of how slow
that some episodes are
and that's just kind of the sad truth
it's kind of essential
Eric Jeanette says
did I just do your name wrong too Eric
Jeannette says I feel your pain a few
people get my last name right is it
Jeanette or Janae
my tummy you see that because I feel
like I just got it wrong too true harm
our true harm says our really cool stuff
they chose not to include so far
not that I can
not that I can tell I feel like they
haven't really cut anything
which is why I'm still giving the show a
pass for being a little bit slow in some
parts as long as they don't cut anything
though as long as they don't put
anything on the chopping block I'm fine
with the added things I can sit through
the added things
okay uh Maya says hi Quinn I showed some
of my Chinese friends your video
um on Billy Billy because I believe you
make the best science fiction videos on
the internet thank you so much thank you
so much
um yeah
um
although are there many videos about
three-body problem in China
they lack the depth and created okay he
says although there are many videos
about three body problem in China they
lack the depth and creativity shown in
your videos that's very nice of you to
say thank you so much
someone says whoa just got on um we need
a hat come out well I need a haircut you
know I should have gotten my hair cut
before I did this stream but you know
we're just dealing with it today we're
dealing with it today
uh Eric Jeanette says people usually
emphasize the wrong syllable that's just
interesting
uh skuka
skuma much says in my country novel
adaptations were stretched to like a
hundred episodes this is not new to me
what country are you from
interesting
death mullet says the universe
flickering was underwhelming
well I feel like some of it boils down
to a difference of how you see stuff in
your head and then howlett's portrayed
on screen because like some things in
your mind can be really really
terrifying like in the book when you
when when the build up to the universe
flickering part and when you finally see
it it's definitely
really really spooky and really scary uh
but sometimes like it doesn't translate
necessarily as well and sometimes that
just happens like that
and it seems like they're extending uh
the one character to the the character
that's at the satellite I don't know if
he is uh
really famous in China maybe but he was
also in one of the advertisements
uh during the middle of the show he was
Professor E says sucks you aren't making
any money off of that site they stole
your content
well yeah technically but I'm not sure
is it I'm not I'm not sure what the
legality of it is it even possible for
me as an American to make money off of
Billy Billy being a Chinese site I I
tried to look into it but there's a
whole verification process where they
have to verify my ID and it's the whole
thing is in Chinese and even when you
translate it it's really hard
a lot of weird things going on so I'm
not really sure how to begin the process
of even uploading my content to Billy
Billy even if I wanted to
uh maybe like there's a someone that
speaks Chinese
um that can help me out a little bit
with it because I just don't really know
what I'm doing
um and I don't really look at it like
they stole my content I feel like you
know
I'm not like stressing about it it's
just like I'm just happy that I have a
whole entire other I'm happy that my
content can be viewed by a whole other
group of people you know what I mean
um I don't really say yeah I mean
technically stolen but that's it is what
it is at least they translated it I
would love someone I would love to have
someone to translate my videos in the
Chinese I need to find someone that can
do subtitles so that I can get my videos
translated into Chinese and then
optimally I want to start like maybe
Quinn's ideas and Billy Billy and just
uploading my videos to YouTube and to
Billy Billy at the same time with
Chinese subtitles that'd be great if I
could ultimately get to that point in
time but as far as I'm concerned um
these video uploads of mine have been
happening for years
um so it's I can't really complain about
it now
um Maya says Mia says Billy Billy ad
revenue is much less than YouTube but
posting them on Billy Billy with Chinese
sub is a good is good exposure yeah I I
agree and I think we'll ultimately end
up doing that
um yeah
someone says can't you just take them
right off Billy Billy
I didn't upload them
so I don't really I can't really take
them off I don't know if I I don't
really I don't really want to I don't
really go in like because some of these
have hundreds of thousands of views
right and I'm just kind of happy that
people have that content there to watch
you know what I mean so I don't want to
get it taken down
um but I would like to have my own Billy
Billy Channel That's official that all
of that content could go to
so yeah
yeah
exactly little finger because who knows
how many Chinese followers that I've
gotten from those Billy Billy videos
being uploaded
and also it's not just me like when I'm
scrolling around I saw content from
Daniel Green I saw um hello future me
there's lots of American YouTubers that
get put on Billy Billy so
someone says hey I'm waiting for a
modern novel to tie into the Hawaii
telescopes as I'm born and raised on a
big island by the way handsome without
the hat but the Mystique the Mystique of
the Hat
um Philip Costello says Daniel Green
stopped reading after book one to each
his own I don't know if Daniel Green's
as big of a Sci-Fi guy
as I am
yeah so yeah to each his own
to each his own so what else about
um clear body problem episodes five
through ten can we talk about
um
I just remember saying during episode 10
man I really wish
that we could have gotten to this sooner
because like once we got to episode 10
and she got to reading Silent Spring I'm
like oh yeah this is the good stuff and
they start looking up at the radio tower
oh that this should have been like
episode five or episode six
or you know it should have been a lot
earlier on but I'm happy we got to it
because I found it very interesting and
this part in the book is also very
interesting I don't know if you guys
know about Silent Spring and what the
whole deal with that was but we learned
about this in I think Middle School
elementary school or something and
environmental science and it had to do
with pesticides
um so they were just trying to get rid
of the insects that were attacking crops
and ruining crops but the chemicals that
they were using
stayed in the environment and it would I
forget exactly what it would do but I
think it would like kill all the bugs
and then the animals eating the bugs
would have food so they would die off
and then the animals that ate the bigger
animals started to die off so the point
of the book was that eventually if we
keep using these types of pesticides
that are killing off the environment
we're gonna go it's just gonna be a
Silent Spring imagine like a watering
hole like a spring of animals
full of life buzzing with life you got
you got birds and you got frogs you got
insects imagine now that there's nothing
Silent Spring
so basically because of this book
um
certain types of pesticides were banned
so that that essentially didn't happen
because we were like literally about to
destroy the environment and so that's
really really interesting
um it's a really interesting read too
um so this part in uh three body yeah
wenji becoming obsessed with it I think
ah it's so interesting and it makes so
much sense because it's just about like
the recklessness of kind of just humans
if you leave people will talk about like
oh regulation we don't need all this
regulation but if you don't have regular
regulations people will build houses
without nails
and then sell it to a family
we need the regulations because people
will destroy the world people will
absolutely destroy the world for a
profit so yeah yeah so that's the kind
of like when you think about yawinji and
her whole sentiment cinnamon it's like
humans aren't that great you know it's
kind of like you can almost see where
yeah wenji is coming from ultimately
because it's like humans are not that
great and we kind of mess stuff up all
the time and it kind of sucks
kind of sucks
um so yeah I really I really liked
episode 10 a lot just because I was very
happy to see something different than
just Dasha and zubing and Wang sitting
in a room reiterating what we've already
heard like the last three episodes of
candy and I mean
have you noticed that all that the whole
female cast is extremely attractive a
little unrealistic I have 100 noticed
that
um there's a lot of variants in the
choice of male actors I noticed but the
female the female actresses
um are all very pretty
um I'll have a I'll have a similar look
and that's a little bit it's a little
bit weird I'm not gonna lie
um typically uh in America especially
nowadays diversity is a big thing so
we're like different
looks of people like different
um weights of people just like just a
bunch of different looks not just like
racially speaking but there's just like
a lot of variants and looks and here it
definitely does seem like there's like
one
look that they want for the women and
then the guys can just look a bunch of
different ways you got Dosha doesn't
look anything like Wang and then you got
the guy that was at the telescope he got
the military guy looks totally different
and they got ding Yi has his own
different look so it's like I don't know
that is a little bit like I definitely
did notice that I definitely didn't
notice that
[Music]
um
uh
someone says yeah wenji is is George
Carlin if he chilled out do you mean if
he chilled out so George Carlin would
have been even more extra
um so so yeah so like I said earlier um
if you have not seen episode 5 through
10 yet
just get to episode 10 I feel like think
I think you'll enjoy the game episodes
for sure the game episodes are really
weird and interesting and it's like what
the hell is even happening and this is
so weird and trippy
um and then episode 10 I feel like is
when we finally start to get to the
place for me where the book like really
took off right it was it was like once
we got to the red Coast chapters it was
like oh yeah here we go here we go
um and they're already foreshadowing
they're already foreshadowing it in the
show well they really have been the
whole time but we really got the first
like Eerie glance up towards the radio
tower
um and um
it's really cool because I like this
part in the book so much because
I don't know I love the Trope of being
in like a small town and then there's
like a science lab and because of the
experiments at the science lab
um weird things are happening in the
town like with the rain and like all the
weird things I really like that Trope as
on this episode we get we get the first
hint of that when we forget the first
like glancing up at the radio tower
where yahwenji will ultimately be
um so
that was really cool and I I really
liked the vibe of episode 10 and the
change of scenery finally the change of
scenery
um because it's just it gets a little
bit like dragging seeing the same sense
over and over again and I get that
that's helping them
that's helping them um
cut you know cut budget but you know
it's it's a little weird to see
something or whatever anyway someone
says AKA says I'm not seeing the Donate
button
um this channel is not monetized right
now but if you want to support Quinn's
ideas Quinn streams you can check out
the patreon link in the description I
mean you can also check out the PayPal
link if you want it if you want to
support the channel but you know no no
worries about that this is a more chill
stream
it's cool that we got um I actually like
the amount of people that we have here
right now because watching on whenever
whenever we're streaming on Quinn's
ideas
I have ADHD so like focusing for me I
can I have to hyper focus on like things
if I'm talking I can't read the chat
right if I'm like looking at something I
can't read the chat and I can barely
talk so with less people being here it's
like I can see everybody's comments I
can get everybody to come comments in
the chat and I can still talk and I
really like not having the chat rushing
all the time because it's like ah I'm
missing everything so yeah
foreign
someone says interesting that Asimov
made it to China just something you
never think about he was the most
prolific writer of the 20th century well
of course Asimov made it to China
um you can tell that Shish and Lindsay
is ex is um inspired by tons of American
authors and American sci-fi
um there's Star Trek references in death
sent there's a ship called the
Enterprise
um so yeah um
yeah I feel like when something is that
famous everyone people all around the
world
are going to read it people all around
the world world read science fiction
people all around the world read like um
a song as ice and fire Harry Potter like
those major series like it was
everywhere they're everywhere
what's what I'm uh very curious to see
in the future is how the three body
problem will take off in America it's
already pretty popular in America uh but
I'm curious to see after the David and
Dan show under the Netflix show how much
it's gonna really expand in popularity
and you know honestly I'm not I'm not
rooting against David and Dan
um I was angry with them for a long time
for what they did to the ending of Game
of Thrones for what they did to Game of
Thrones but you know ultimately I want
the three-body problem American
adaptation to be really really good
because I feel like I think I want more
people to read this series because I
really like it and I think it's very
interesting it has it's an it's a new
it's it's a new science fiction classic
I feel like
wait Queen which is your favorite book
in the series as I said a little bit
earlier in the Stream my favorite
favorite favorite favorite book in the
series is the Dark Forest I just think
it's I think it's the best one it's got
to me the best climax it's got like it's
the point where it's like okay we gotta
get going maybe we're getting moving
um I will put after saying that too I
will say that the first part of this
book
drags a little bit
definitely drags when we we
introducing some new characters at the
beginning of this
and
um
the parts in the beginning with the
character luogi who is actually my
favorite character are pretty slow I
will say it is a little bit slow but it
gets going and then it's like Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam it's so good once it kicks
off
um
pretty much everybody that I've
recommended to it has liked it except
for one person one of my good friends
did not like descent but did not like
Dark Forest I mean but you know who
cares about her she's insane hahaha
if someone says so funds will strike
David and Dan if he doesn't get it right
for sure they're gonna they're coming
uh death mullet says okay cool mine is
destined but I agree
chug says I think you're actually the
main popularizer for three-body problem
at this current time is that true
I don't know I don't know I guess maybe
I mean my I guess I guess so like my my
my first three writer Problem video has
like over 2 million views I think so
it's pretty popular I feel like I was
definitely the main popularizer for Dune
for a long time uh now it's like
insanely popular but um it's cool
someone says I try not to get triggered
when someone dislikes books yeah exactly
because not everybody's gonna like
everything
I'm the guy that got you to read read
June oh awesome
I wonder if it's because a female reader
is extremely sexist I like the first
book
I wonder because if it's two of female
reader is extremely sexist I don't think
it was that I think her reasonings for
not liking it were for one
that's in it was really slow and that
put her off a bit and for two she didn't
like
the hubris and the stupidity of humanity
she was like oh I don't she like didn't
understand that Humanity kept making the
same idiotic decisions over and over and
I basically had to like sit her down and
she kind of got it after this I was like
look that's what we do in the real world
that's just like how humans are like we
repeat the same dumb mistakes you can't
really get mad at for just like saying
for just pointing out how we really are
we we as a collective organism the human
collected organism is a little bit is a
little dumb right individually we're
intelligent well not everybody but like
as as a collective species we make it
takes us a long time to learn so you
know
it takes us a long time to learn as a
collective species
what's the next three ready problem that
will hit YouTube popularity children of
time
um maybe I mean My Children Of Time
video from I don't know like six or
seven months ago
got way more views than I ever imagined
like no one was talking about that book
um
and I posted it and it's a big big hit
on YouTube for me
um so much well actually
before the video even really took off
the author Adrian Tchaikovsky saw it
um so Adrian tikasi actually saw that
video he watches my videos or at least
the videos
um that I have on his series at least uh
so he's really cool
with doom you read it better than the
cheaper
um ebooks you had annotations as we all
would interesting
hmm
someone mentioned slowing down light in
the vacuum though a race for absolute
zero is actually a nice documentary to
watch really is that an actual thing
um in in in Destin when shishly is
talking about slowing down the speed of
light than a vacuum I just thought oh
that's a weird concept that I've never
heard of I didn't know that was actually
something that people are like
attempting to do or attempting to learn
about that's interesting but of course
they are like science is always trying
to learn everything
Jing song Yang says Quinn check out
wandering Earth 2 the movie by I saw the
trailer on that is that on Netflix
um I have not read wandering Earth a
book but I think James
has I think James has
so guys I think that we have
done everything we've covered um
episodes five through ten I'm given my
review so I think that we should wrap
things up I want to say thank you for
everyone that joined on my first stream
on this channel it's been really really
awesome to have you guys here on the
first freaking stream
uh thank you guys so much I didn't know
how many people were actually going to
show up I mean watch this stream
considering it's the first stream on
this particular Channel Please Subscribe
if you're not subscribed to this
particular Channel
um you can watch the three body problem
show I thought it was linked in the
description James can you link it please
it's on YouTube it's on the 10 cent
um
YouTube channel I think there are about
five or six episodes available for free
right now
um I think I don't know how the free
episode release schedule Works they
released them kind of intermittently I
don't know
um but if you become a member on 10 cent
then you can get them like every day
except for on Saturdays I believe they
skip a day I don't know but thank you
guys so much for watching thanks for
coming here I love you all so much it's
been fun reviewing the three body
problem with you guys we'll be back
later on to review episodes 11 through
however many I watch
um peace out guys love you guys